okay I gotta say it's amazing to me that
only about two years ago I made this
video in which I said instagram has
become you know my favorite social media
platform amazing that in such a short
span of time well I guess not that short
in social media years Instagram fell all
the way down the list to become my least
favorite in the video that inspired my
own Casey nice tats Instagram I love you
nice that says the Instagram it's pure
just the good stuff
both of us were reacting to Instagram
against Facebook which had by then been
spoiled with the kind of virtual version
of keeping up with the Joneses the
desire to show others how very happy and
cool your life is even then we were
leery of what Instagram might become so
leery that we made rules here remind one
don't take pictures of food too don't
take pictures of yourself and three
don't take pictures of you clearly
having but now food photographers are an
unfortunate breed of their own though
there's no stopping them the chances
that they'll infect the rest of us are
relatively small people held out on
selfies for a while in the way an old
and unsteady dam holds back a river
the third rule is the hardest to follow
yet the most insidious it works on the
same insecurities as the first party
pictures composed poorly without a
thought began to march on to our fees
like orcs nice that treats Instagram
like a photo album and photo albums are
fine with me but when the social aspect
is added the album concept is altered
chemically so to speak and that it
becomes a new thing it becomes a balm
for the symptoms of sadness a substitute
for creative accomplishment a PR tool
among friends
social media is an incredibly effective
way to present to the world the most
current conception you have of who you
are
all for the purpose of convincing not
the world but yourself that that
conception is true that you're not
swinging in the dark when it comes to
what you think you like or what you
think you love or we're born to do it's
so effective because it has a built-in
system of reinforcement they come in the
form of likes and retweets and favorites
in this system the more like something
gets the truer it is without those
reinforcements I suspect the whole
system would cease to function or at
least it wouldn't occupy the same
central space in our lives think about
it would you continue to use Facebook or
Twitter or tumblr if what you posted
there never got a reaction what I
continue to use YouTube if they did away
with the view camp or likes or the
comments I don't know and like most
people who seek some kind of spotlight I
am probably more susceptible than most
to this insidious form of self-deception
now I happen to believe that there's
very little in life that isn't some form
of self-deception all kinds of
expression are certainly mixed up with
that this doesn't mean don't post
anything to YouTube or tumblr or Twitter
it just means that if you have some
respect for Humanity and expression why
not try restricting yourself a little to
posting things that you believe have
some aesthetic or educational value
which brings me back to Instagram and
the fuck-you project I'm so grumpy about
Instagram because by rights it should be
a platform for interesting
creative ideas and plenty of people use
it that way a couple weeks ago I had an
idea for a portraiture series that would
allow people to get in touch with their
inner [__] you I'm obsessed with
portraits and swearing and the social
constructs around swearing and in my
personal life I am completely adverse to
confrontation so the mix of all that I
think makes for a potentially
interesting photo series that is just
irreverent enough for Instagram okay so
my challenge to you is to look at your
presence on social media and think about
why you post what you post start
something new on one of those platforms
that you find interesting or a value you
may come to the conclusion that I am
speaking out of turn and I should just
let people live their lives and post all
the selfies and music lyrics that they
want to post and why don't I stop
projecting my insecurities on the rest
of humanity and if you feel that way hey
[__] you man a good evening
I do not attempt to adjust your radio
there is nothing wrong we have taken
control as to bring you this special
show we will return it to you as soon as
you our group a welcome to station w fu
n K better known as we funk or deeper
still the mothership connection home of
the extraterrestrial brothers dealers of
funky music P funk uncut funk